[STING]
NETO MARIN: Hello, I'm
Neto and we are here
for another "Behind
the Actions" episode.
And today, I have here Aza.
Hey, how are you doing, Aza?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: I'm good.
How are you?
NETO MARIN: Good, good.
And thanks for joining me.
And just introduce
yourself to our audience.
What you're doing on our team,
what's your daily basis job.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Sure.
My name is Aza.
And I'm an engineer at Developer
Relations for Google Assistant.
My main duty is to provide
some tooling for developers
to improve their productivity.
NETO MARIN: Cool, cool.
So all the cool stuff people
are using in their development,
you kind of have some
responsibility on that, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: That's right.
Yeah, you can think
of it that way.
NETO MARIN: Or you
can have [INAUDIBLE]..
No, I'm kidding.
So today, we're going to build
something on top of the Digital
Goods platform, right?
So what is Digital Goods?
Because when you say "purchase,"
there's so many different ways
to purchase things, to
have different things
you could purchase
for front-end action.
So I know that we have some
different products, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
Well, if you use
Digital Goods, it
will automatically
allow your application
to be available on 2 billion
services that currently support
Assistant, including smart to
displays, phones, Google Home.
NETO MARIN: Headphones.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
And for example, when
we say product types,
we have the one-time purchase.
It's some products
that you purchase once,
and maybe you can
purchase again.
I'm going to explain this with
more details in a few seconds.
But also, it can
have subscriptions.
I think these are the two main
categories, you could say.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yeah, they are.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, and then
on the one-time purchase,
we have, for example,
the consumable
and the non-consumable
products, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes,
consumable and non-consumable.
NETO MARIN: Yeah,
can you explain
a little bit what the difference
is between these two products?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yeah, so you can
think of consumable products as
purchases that can be done over
and over and over.
So for example, if you
buy currency in a game,
you can re-purchase it as
many times as you want.
Versus non-consumable,
it's something
that can be done only one time.
So, for example, let's
say I want to buy
a specific feature in my app--
NETO MARIN: Or an expansion
for the same game, for example.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
This is a good example
of non-consumable.
NETO MARIN: Yeah,
because then you won't--
at least I imagine you won't--
once you buy another expansion
or the same expansion,
like a premium package,
and then you don't need to
take care yourself about this.
Google Play platform
will take care about it.
So if you try to purchase
again, for example,
and you didn't consume
that product, we will say,
hey, you can't buy this.
But we'll explain this
on the code a little bit.
I just said Google Play, right?
Why I said Google Play?
There is a reason, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yeah, because in fact,
Digital Goods is reusing
the same infrastructure
that Google Play uses for
authorizing and performing
all of their purchases.
So we get all these
years of experience
to make the flow as seamless
as possible for the users.
NETO MARIN: Yeah,
and the great point
is Google Play store is
available in over almost,
I think, 200 countries.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: In each country,
the Google Play team
has been doing a
great job on finding
the correct forms of
payment for each country
so that users can use
their own credit card,
or they can use carrier
billing, for example.
But the developer doesn't
care about it because it just
offers the product.
The user purchases the
product, and then we
receive the money from Google.
So they don't need to care
about accepting credit card,
making contracts with credit
card companies, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
It's all done by Google
with all the Google security
and everything in mind.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, nice.
And also the subscriptions.
The subscriptions is also
a very nice feature, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
It's, in fact, my favorite one.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
Yeah, because it allows
you to, for example,
set up some recurring
purchase frequent.
So people can buy--
I don't know-- a subscription
to your news app,
and then you pay every month, or
yearly, or quarterly, whatever.
And also there are
some cool features,
like you have free trial.
You can send invite codes.
You have progressive price.
So it can have
introduction price.
So there's a bunch of features.
And also, all the back
end is the same, right?
The back end, it's the same back
end you are using for Android,
you're going to use for the
Actions on Google, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly, yes.
NETO MARIN: So all
the features that we
have available on
the subscription
part and the purchase
time, the API's management,
it's available--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Out of the box, yeah.
NETO MARIN: And this is
great, because then you
don't need to develop this
kind of thing by yourself.
You can use this.
And if you're already an
Android developer, it's great.
Because like Aza said, you can
expand your consumer market
to over 2 billion devices.
And this is very cool.
So I can purchase something
on my phone, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: And then
use the Google Home Hub,
for example, to--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: To
actually use it, yeah.
NETO MARIN: And this is great.
And if you're a
non-Android developer,
you only have a few steps more
than an Android developer,
right?
You need to set up your
Google Play account.
And then you have to
fill all the requirements
from the Google Play.
But again, we have
all these documented
in our documentation,
right, Aza?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
NETO MARIN: So all
the steps there,
they can go set up the account.
And after I have
this account, if I
don't have an
Android app yet, do
I have to do
pre-development steps?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yeah, there's a few.
So in fact, you have to
set up brand verification
in the console.
That way, Google can verify
that your digital purchases are
essentially legit and verified.
NETO MARIN: OK.
Yeah, this is an
interesting point
because in our
episode, of course,
we don't have time to go through
the brand verification process
because it can take
up to 48 hours,
but we're going to show you
where you have to set up this,
and how the flow
looks like for you.
And then, if you
have any questions,
check our documentation.
You will find all
the details there.
But yes, I think,
even we have this step
of setting up the
account, then they
need to create an
Android project, right?
Because in the Android
project, we have the package.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yes, the XML file
that contains all the
metadata about your app.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
And with this
configuration for your app,
you can use the same package.
Actually, you need to use the
same package in your Actions
on Google back-end code,
to match the same products.
And you can have all the--
how can I say-- all the
advantage, all the features,
pre-created for the
Google Play Store
through the Google Assistant.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
For example, you can
ask an API to return
all the available products
that My Play Store supports.
So in just one API call, you
can get it out of the box.
NETO MARIN: Nice, nice.
OK, so after you do
this on your Android,
you can just create this
project in the Play Console,
go back to the Actions Console.
So it's kind of a long
process, right, Aza?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So
we're going, today,
to cover this in a
good amount of time.
We're going to-- we are using--
how can I say-- a simplified
version, for example, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
In fact, I have a screenshot
of what the implementation will
look like with a user.
I can show it now.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, sure.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So you can
see here in the screen that--
NETO MARIN: Can you explain
to us what's going on here?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah,
so this is essentially
a sample interaction
between the user
and this sample app that
they're building right now.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So
the user starts the app.
And the app asks the user
if they want to start the--
to see what this Play Store
has available for purchase.
NETO MARIN: So it's
like I'm asking
what products you have in your
catalog or something like that.
You can say that this
is the catalog, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
That's a better way to say it.
So you can see here, I say yeah.
And then app lists
all the products
that it has-- premium car,
unlimited gas, and so on.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And then it
asks which one does user like.
And then the user
selects one of those
and it sort of goes through
the flow of the transaction.
NETO MARIN: Nice, yeah.
And the good point
is the user even
don't need to leave the
Assistant environment.
They don't need to complete
the transaction on their phone
if they already have set up
the payment on the Google
Assistant.
The Google Assistant,
for example,
if we're already buying videos,
movies, from Google Play movie,
you can use the same account,
because it's either your credit
cards or personal
account, to purchase
these additional goods, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly, yes.
NETO MARIN: Now, this is cool
because we don't need even
to take our phone to
validate something.
It would do the voice match
so the Google Assistant
knows who are you.
For example, if my wife
tried to do something,
we would purchase
on her credit card.
If I tried to purchase with
my voice with Voice Match,
it would purchase on
my credit card, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So yes, but we
already said to the console
that we are using the
Transactions platform,
but we actually need to verify--
link my website, my Android app.
Because how the console will
know that this action is
related to my Android app
or the Android project
in the Play Console, right?
So what you're going to do
now is go to the-- there is
an option--
Advanced Options they can find.
And then the brand verification.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
So all in one console, you
can configure the brand
verification.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, so
there is two steps.
First, you need to
connect a website.
So this is done using the
Google Webmaster tool.
So you need to go
on the Webmaster,
check your URL there.
Going to be some instructions.
Upload the file.
And then our crawler
going to link your website
to your Webmaster Tool account.
And then you will be able
to connect the website here.
And then after
connecting the website,
it's time to connect
the Android app.
The difference
here is because we
need to refer to the
package name, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yes, the package name
from the Android app.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, and
the point here important,
we are not showing here
in the Play Console,
but a similar process must
be done on the Android site
because there, to
verify your brand,
it's linked to the deep link
configurations on your Play
Console, OK?
Too much, but no problem.
Look in our documentation.
We're going to link
you to the right page
where you're going to
check all this information.
But just keep in mind that after
doing all these connections,
both consoles--
Actions on Google Console
and Play Console--
they will understand that we
are the same project, right?
The same developer.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So OK,
they have this--
because I said up to 48
hours because the first step,
in general, takes
up to 24 hours.
And the second step
takes another 24 hours.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So up
to 48 hours, you'll
be able to start selling stuff.
So if you need to
sell something today,
don't start this morning.
So you need two days
to have this enabled.
OK, cool.
But people want to see actual
development, actual calls.
This is just bureaucratic
stuff that we do only
when you configure
the project, right?
So you showed the conversation.
This is pretty good, when the
user asks about the catalog.
Where are we going to
handle this conversation?
Are we going to use Dialogflow?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes,
so we'll use Dialogflow
for natural language processing
to make the conversation more
intelligent.
And then we'll use
Firebase functions
to set up the fulfillment.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
So remember we are using
Firebase functions,
so it means that we're going to
use the Node.js client library.
But if you want to use
the Java client library,
also this feature is supported
under the Java client library,
so you can use your
preferred language
if you don't want
to use Node.js.
OK, can you show us--
can you go to the data flow
and show the intents you have
and how you create this show?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, sure.
So in the screenshot that
we showed in the beginning,
the user starts the
app by invoking it.
And this is handled in this
default welcome intent.
NETO MARIN: Sure.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And--
NETO MARIN: And
the welcome intent,
did you change it to say,
hey, you can buy stuff?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So if we look at
it, essentially that
first prompt that we saw in
the screenshot is defined here.
And after that,
we allow the user
to either start building
the order or quit.
And that's what those
two intents represent.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
You said a good name--
build the order.
So build the order is
the intent or the way
that the user will ask for
something to buy, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So yes, please.
How does it work?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So
essentially, the main--
the meat of the logic is
handled in the what fulfillment.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
But this intent
just handles the annoying part.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Great part.
For example, can you go on
the top of the page here?
Yeah.
So I'm seeing here the phrases.
For any phrases, you add some.
Let's go do it, yeah,
yes, of course, sure.
This is because in
the welcome intent,
you ask if the user would like
to purchase something, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
NETO MARIN: And then
you are picturing
the potential answers.
But imagine the developers are
creating something different,
and they want to
handle something like,
hey, I would like to see
what's available to purchase.
They should also add
this training phrase,
or create another instance to
handle different approaches
just to make clear.
Because maybe someone-- oh, I
need you do this on the welcome
and just handle yes or no.
But sometimes they only
handle questions about,
what can I buy?
What is available to buy, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
That would be the best practice.
NETO MARIN: OK.
Good, good.
So let's imagine, here, we have
some of these kinds of phrases.
And then you said
the next step is
just, send these to the back-end
for a few minutes, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
So let's go to Fulfillment.
NETO MARIN: Yes, please.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So here I
have just some starter code
where I define constants
and some imports.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: But let
us first actually create
the web hook--
the intent handler
for the particular intent.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So
what I'm going to do
is I already have this
nifty constant defined
for build order.
NETO MARIN: Cool.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And this is
very standard client library
code, as you can see.
But essentially, I want to
tell the user, hey, here
are the options.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Which
one do you want, right?
NETO MARIN: Nice.
So at this point you're going
to the Google Play Store API--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: --and retrieving
all the products that
are available, and then
telling about these products
to the user, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So I
can say something like,
here's what I have available.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And then,
I can say, those are the SKUs.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
then, which one do you want?
NETO MARIN: SKUs, what is this?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So SKUs--
you can think of them
as your product IDs
they define in the Play Store.
Typically, you define them first
in your Play Store, and then--
NETO MARIN: It's like
a product ID, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Your
product reference.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: All the
product management
is made through
the Play Console.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So to add products,
to remove product, or manage
your product, you must go
to the Google Play Console.
And there, you're going
to add these SKUs.
These SKUs are defined by you,
so you don't need to remember.
This is something that
you have in your back-end
in your library.
In this case, for
example, Aza has
as constants in the project.
And like he's doing here,
you can use our sample
to extract some of these
constants, some status,
right, so they
can take advantage
of all of this stuff
done by Aza, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
So actually, going
back to the SKUs,
I need to find them, right?
So I created this function
that essentially calls
the digital purhase
API and gets the SKUs.
So it expects the
conversation ID that you
get from the conversation.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
And you can you show the
code on the get_skus?
So just make some few
comments so the developers
can understand what's
happening here.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
So the get_skus is right here.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
essentially what we're doing
is we're first
authorized with the API
by getting the
JavaScript tokens.
NETO MARIN: The tokens, right.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
then we make this request
to the get_skus endpoint.
NETO MARIN: So yeah,
this is, for example--
the fetch(endpoints(get_skus))
is the actual API call, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yeah, exactly.
So the get_skus is this
endpoint right here.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
And these endpoints are, at
least in our documentation,
default. So you have
all the end points.
You have your product,
your package name.
This is why package name is
so important because here, I
see that we are using it here
to create the URL, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
Yes, it's part of the URL.
NETO MARIN: So a cool
thing, again, it's
all JSON-based, right?
So it's just using JSON.
If I don't want
to use JS or Java,
I'm using Neto's new language.
So I can use JSON.
And it's good.
It's great because
I can see that you
can wrap these and reuse
in other projects, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: Nice, nice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So--
NETO MARIN: OK.
These SKUs are going to
be returned as a JSON,
and the client library will
return an array, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So this will be
an array of SKUs.
And here, I just defined
quickly what the typical SKU
would look like.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So you
can see all the properties
and everything.
So this will return
an array of those.
But we want to make a list of
strings to make it simpler.
So I actually created
another function that--
NETO MARIN: He's a
very handy guy, huh?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
BuildSimpleResponse.
So--
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So we
just expect that and--
NETO MARIN: All it's
going to do is just
break this array in title,
description, and price, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
a comma, yeah, between.
NETO MARIN: And a comma.
OK, so again, this
is a sample, right?
If you are developing
something for production,
please use our base
cards, use carousel.
You have a bunch
of resources you
can use to make it more visual.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: And
remember, sometimes
reading the product's
name, if you have,
like, 10 products
on the conversation,
it's not that good, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So you
can do pagination.
There's a lot of
best practices you
can check in our
Conversation Design
page in our documentation.
But just keep this in mind.
You don't want to read
10 products available.
You can showcase on the list.
Or, for example, say the
first three products,
and show the rest of the
products in a carousel,
for example.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
Yeah.
This is, in fact,
the best practice.
NETO MARIN: Cool.
Yeah, best practice.
[LAUGHS]
OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
One last one step.
We want to save the SKUs
so we can reuse them later.
So we store them
in user storage.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So we're done with this intent.
NETO MARIN: And this
is enough to have
all the products available,
read to the user, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
Yeah, that's all we need.
Just a few lines of code.
NETO MARIN: OK.
And when I hear the product
list, then I can say, OK, yeah,
I want gas, for
example, premium gas.
What is-- because
you offered it to me,
then I'm going to say
the name of the products.
And do I need to create
entity, or will the system
handle this for me?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
So you will have
to create entity.
Typically, the best
practice is to create
entity per product ID.
NETO MARIN: Per product ID, OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
And then, in fact, we
can show you in the console.
In the entities, we
have the SKU entity.
It has all the product IDs
we have in the Play Store,
and all the possible synonyms.
So Dialogflow can sort of--
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
And this is important because
without these entities,
the Dialogflow
wouldn't be able to map
what you're saying to what
products are available, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: And
remember, sometimes you
have, also, to localize this.
So use the Dialogflow
localization stuff
so it can create
another language entity.
And then you can add, for
example, Brazilian Portuguese,
Spanish, whatever
you can add here,
and add the variations
for the name, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: Cool.
OK.
I said premium.
What's the next step?
What is the Assistant
going to do?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
Well, in the conversation,
we ask the user, hey,
which one do you want?
So the user will reply to us
with the SKU that they like.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And this is
done in "Initiate the Purchase"
intent.
NETO MARIN: OK.
So actually, now we are starting
to make the purchase, right?
Until now we, are just
building the order.
I like the name of the intents.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Exactly, yeah.
NETO MARIN: So, now we
are actually starting
to purchase something, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
So in fact, in this
intent, you can
see all the highlighted
portions are the entities,
the Dialogflow extracted.
NETO MARIN: Oh, nice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So again, all the logic is
done in the fulfillment.
So shall we go there?
NETO MARIN: Of course, please.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So
actually, one last thing
in the previous intent--
because this is the asynchronous
call, we may have to--
NETO MARIN: Oh, sure.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
--do some steps there.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: OK.
So let's define intent handler
for "Initiate the Purchase."
NETO MARIN: "Initiate
the Purchase."
Right.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So again,
it's going to have a--
NETO MARIN: A conversation
and then a SKU.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yep.
NETO MARIN: OK.
And this SKU that the user
said was mapped to the--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--entities.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Perfect.
Yep.
So essentially,
the client library
provides this helper
class CompletePurchase
that will kick start all
the [INAUDIBLE] transaction
flow with the Assistant.
NETO MARIN: Yeah,
this is the point.
For example, this
is something I like
very much on the
Android platform,
and also on the Assistant.
As developers, we
don't need to developer
all the screens for credit
card verification, account--
all these requirements.
Of course, because it's a
security requirement also,
because I need to
validate my account.
I need to check everything else.
This is good because it's
taking care of it for us, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
So this will trigger
all the payment flow.
We can say that, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
Yeah, as you can see,
we'll do a demo later.
Yeah.
It'll be--
NETO MARIN: OK, OK.
I'm just curious.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's go.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: All right.
So essentially,
it takes a SKU ID.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And so you
remember how we stored the SKUs
in the conversation storage?
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So that's
where we'll actually use it.
We're going to fetch the
SKUs from the storage
and use that SKU ID.
NETO MARIN: Cool.
And [? that'll void ?] those
from making other network
requests.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Cool.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So we have selectedSku.skuId.
So again, as you see, skuID
is part of the SKU object.
NETO MARIN: Object, yeah.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So that's
what this line of code does.
NETO MARIN: Good.
Cool.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So how to
get the selected SKU, again,
there is a helper
function findSkuById--
NETO MARIN: Mm-hmm.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: --that
expects conversation--
NETO MARIN: Conversation.
OK.
Yeah, the conversation
is [INAUDIBLE]
because then you need to close
conversation or do something,
right?
You need to keep assessing
the conversation.
So it's--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, or
for things like conversation
ID or--
NETO MARIN: Yeah, yeah.
OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
And then I want to say something
like, sure, here you go.
NETO MARIN: And then
when the Assistant says,
here you go, it will start
to trigger the payment
flow, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And one last
thing we also need to store.
We need to remember
which SKU we actually
purchased in this step.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So--
Yeah, we must verify--
we must store what SKU the
user actually selected, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Right, exactly.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: All right, so
that should do for this intent.
NETO MARIN: OK.
So after that, all
the requirements
will be done by the Assistant.
So if the product is
declined, the credit card
is not accepted, or there is
an error with the product--
how we can handle this?
Because I imagine all this--
OK, I start at this point.
But it won't go back to me,
and then I send back, right?
This will be triggered by
the Home Assistant, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
So once we send this new
CompletePurchase object
to the Assistant--
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
--this process
will start with the
Assistant, and it
will return us the
status code with how
the operation went through.
NETO MARIN: And this will
be triggered by an event?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Oh, that's right.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
So we have to map this
event in our agents, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
So in the final
intent of this agent
where I've described
purchase status.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And it takes
actions_intent_COMPLETE_PURCHASE
event.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, this
is very important, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, because if
you don't map this event here,
you won't be able to receive
the result of the purchase.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: And
you will never know
the purchase ID, the receipt.
So it would be a mess.
You don't know that
the user actually
did the purchase, right?
OK.
Of course, you can
go through the API
and check out the purchase.
But on your flow, the user
will get back to your action.
Your action won't
respond to that,
so it's not a good practice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah, it
won't be a very good user
experience.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Great.
So remember, add these intents
to handle these events.
But then we don't need to add
training phrases or nothing,
right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Nope.
Nothing.
In fact, all the experience
will be through the Assistant.
Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Cool, cool.
So then, you enable
fulfillment, I imagine.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: And then, well,
the fulfillment again.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: All right.
NETO MARIN: And now you need
to check what happened, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
So there's a bunch of status
codes that the API returns.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
again, I have these constants
that have all of them.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So
what we'll need to do
is create an event handler
for DESCRIBE_PURCHASE_STATUS.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And then--
so the purchase status
will come as an argument
in the conversation.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So
we want to access it
through client library.
NETO MARIN: Client library, OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So
COMPLETE_PURCHASE_VALUE.
NETO MARIN: OK.
And this value for
[INAUDIBLE] for the argument
is also released in our
documentation, right?
It's not something
you just figure out.
You check in the documentation.
It's there, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes, exactly.
Yep.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
It's right there.
And then the purchase status
is part of this argument.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So we
do arg.purchaseStatus.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
now, essentially, we
need to match the status
against all the API code.
NETO MARIN: OK, OK.
Don't need to go through
all these titles.
I think it's not
really necessary.
But there is, for example,
some styles we can--
successful, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Successful.
And maybe, if you
already own the item.
So it will reject it.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Remember when I said
it's consumable or not.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So if you're
trying to purchase again
a product that's consumable,
and you didn't consume it,
what's going to happen is you
won't be able to purchase it.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
This return code with
the already own item--
NETO MARIN: Already own item.
Yeah.
So you need-- so
for example, imagine
you are developing a game
and you are selling coins.
And the user tried to buy more
coin, receive this status.
It's your fault. It's
not the user's fault.
So you should, for
example, consume this.
We're going to talk about
consuming in a little bit.
And then you can consume this.
And then they will be able
to purchase again, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
Yes.
NETO MARIN: And also, there
are other errors, for example,
right?
The transaction declined.
There are some other--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
The entire list is here.
So, UNSPECIFIED, CANCELLED,
CHANGE_REQUESTED.
So for example--
NETO MARIN: Oh, yes.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: A
visitor changed their mind.
NETO MARIN: This is very
interesting, for example.
This is something very cool.
For example, imagine the user
started flow from your action.
And when he's
browsing the products,
OK, no, I changed my mind.
I'm going to buy this other
product, something like that.
You receive a notification
that the order changed.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So you must
restart the order, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So
just keep in mind.
So like I said, we have
very advanced scenarios
that are covered by the sample.
But right now, we are going on
the happy path, I could say.
So OK.
Let's check success and
then put an else just
to [? end ?] the other.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah, sure.
Yeah.
We can do if status equals OK.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
And then maybe--
NETO MARIN: Else.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: If something
went wrong and then--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: API_CODES--
NETO MARIN: It's not
user friendly, please
don't say just something
went wrong for your user.
Please do the correct stuff.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So here, we checked if
it's just OK and owned.
NETO MARIN: Uh-huh.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So we
can say something like--
NETO MARIN: Congrats.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yeah, congratulations.
NETO MARIN: You gave me money.
No, you purchased something.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: You've
successfully purchased an item.
NETO MARIN: OK, cool.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
maybe you can ask, would you
like to do anything else?
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: To
do anything-- maybe they
want to buy something again.
NETO MARIN: I hope so.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
And then if it's already owned--
NETO MARIN: You can say--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Well,
here, yeah, we can say,
sorry, the transaction didn't
happen because you already
own the item.
NETO MARIN: Or, for example,
if I decide it was my mistake,
and I would like to
trigger a consume call.
I know maybe it's not the
right place to do this.
But can you just show
how a consume call
works so they can understand?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Actually, good catch.
I made a bug in my code.
So here, if purchase
went through,
this is when we want to
check if item is consumable,
and then try to consume it.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, yeah.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So again,
there is a utility function
that I wrote--
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
--that can check
if the purchase
item is consumable
based on the consumable IDs.
NETO MARIN: Right.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
consumable IDs is something
that you define yourself.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
Good point, good point.
Because remember, like we said,
the product is defined by you.
So you know what
products are consumable
or not-- you know what
SKUs or subscriptions.
So if you want to keep
these in your library,
or use your own API to retrieve
these each time you do--
but in this case, Aza
has an array, right--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Mm-hmm.
NETO MARIN: --for
all the product
IDs because it's a sample.
But again, maybe you
want to do something
because you are selling
on other platforms
or selling cross-platform.
So this is your ID
that you define.
This is just to remember,
because I think it's important.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So in my case, it's just gas.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So yep.
And then if it is, then
we want to consume it.
So doConsume is, again,
a utility function.
And it consumes this ID.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
So what's happening
here is the API
will use that same endpoint
plus the consumable endpoint.
And then say, hey, consume this
product ID for this package,
for this user, because
it's all linked.
And then the product
will be consumable.
And then the user will be
able to purchase again.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
That's how it works.
That's the flow.
NETO MARIN: Nice, nice.
OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And then--
NETO MARIN: Let's
finish so we can
test, and see if you will be
allowed to do the deploy dance.
Do you know deploy dance?
Have you rehearsed?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Oh.
Oh, man.
NETO MARIN: Now
you have to dance.
[LAUGHS]
Look, he's--
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Wait, what?
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
He's kind of tense.
I can feel the tension.
OK.
Keep going, keep going.
I'm kidding.
No worries.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: OK.
So if item is already
owned, we just
say it's an already owned item.
And then if anything
else, we just return--
NETO MARIN: Sorry.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
Sorry, I'm trying to--
NETO MARIN: [INAUDIBLE]
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
Again, it's not
the best practice,
but for the purpose
of the sample.
NETO MARIN: No, yes.
Of course, of course.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: All right.
Oops.
OK.
So I think that should be it.
One last thing I just want to
show in the code real quick/
NETO MARIN: Sure, sure.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: In
the doConsume thing,
the doConsume endpoint--
NETO MARIN: Sure.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Again,
consume is an API call.
NETO MARIN: An API call.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yep.
And it has the consume
endpoint provided
by the digital purchase API.
NETO MARIN: Yeah,
and this is important
because you need you to show
the purchase token, right?
This token is returned when
you actually do the purchase.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So imagine,
this purchase can be--
I don't know, maybe the user
purchased this a week ago
and you are consuming
it only now because it
was in his inventory.
And now you are
consuming this product.
So you must keep
this purchase token
at some point in
your application.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: OK, yeah.
NETO MARIN: And then the
doConsume is just this.
Yeah.
NETO MARIN: OK.
Yeah, sounds good.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So I think
I've actually made a typo here.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
I'm going to fix it.
Yeah.
NETO MARIN: No problem.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
All right, so I think
it's ready to be deployed.
NETO MARIN: I want to see that.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Shall we do it?
NETO MARIN: Sure, please.
The audience is waiting,
anxious for that.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
So this is correct.
And do firebase deploy.
NETO MARIN: OK.
I can feel his fear.
So yes, this is the
moment the demo gods
will make some problem happen.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Oh, I hope not.
NETO MARIN: Hope not.
Yes, man.
This is why we hired you.
OK.
So in this point, we are using--
we had the console, we
had the fulfillments.
Set that.
So you are going to
deploy this function.
We can copy the URL, put it
as a fulfillment, [INAUDIBLE]
to the Google Assistant.
Then we can test, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: And can I test
this only with a phone,
or can I test on my device?
For example, in the simulator?
There isn't any
special requirements
since it's a purchase happening?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: No.
So you can use any service you
like, including the simulator.
NETO MARIN: OK.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
But in the simulator,
you can specify that
you want the transaction
to be sandboxed, meaning
that the transaction actually
won't happen.
It will be, like,
a test transaction.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
There's the point.
What is a sandbox?
Because I don't want to spend
money for my own products
during development, how can I
test and make sure that I'm not
spending real money on that?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So let's, quickly
while it's loading,
go to the simulator right here.
NETO MARIN: You
can choose, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So here, the development
sandbox is enabled.
And it's under the
dollar sign, so you can--
NETO MARIN: You are
sure that people are not
spending their money
if they're doing this.
And remember, it can use
[? alphabet ?] [? in ?]
releases to enable
people to test.
And when you have
these users register
as beta testers
and alpha testers,
you can add them to not
pay for the purchase.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Right.
NETO MARIN: So you can
go in the Play Console
and add them as beta
test users using
what account they are
using to do the purchase.
And then they won't be charged.
But this must be done in
the Google Play Console,
just remember, because
all this management--
the accounts and testing--
it's made through the
Google Play Console, right?
So let's see if it's deployed.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: OK.
It did.
NETO MARIN: So that's awesome.
Can you dance?
The deploy dance, man, no?
Yes, it's working.
Yes.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: All right.
NETO MARIN: Yeah, you're
a true [INAUDIBLE]..
So OK.
It's working.
So you have here your web hook.
You want to copy this and
paste there to integrate.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Yeah, so we may
need to get the URL from
the Firebase Console.
NETO MARIN: OK, on Dialogflow.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: So cool.
This screen is very
interesting because you
are accessing the Firebase
project from the back-end.
But I didn't see you
creating a Firebase project.
It's all together, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
So once you create your--
in Actions Console or in
Dialogflow, either way,
it will create all the other--
NETO MARIN: Cloud projects--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yes, cool.
And here you could
see the log, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: The logs?
Yeah.
I'm interested, right
now, in the function name,
the endpoint.
So I'm going to go to
functions, and this URL--
NETO MARIN: Cool.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
--is what I need.
And then we'll use this
URL in a Dialogflow--
NETO MARIN: Cool.
In the fulfillment--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: So, yes.
It's right there.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
It's already there.
OK.
NETO MARIN: Great.
BOTH: Save.
NETO MARIN: So time
to test, right?
Let's see if the code is
working, if everything is OK.
And for now, let's
try on the simulator.
I think it's easier to
see all the conversation
and the formation here, right?
So, please.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: All right.
So we're going to evoke the app.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Sure.
Here's the test version
of Digital Goods.
[BING]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
NETO MARIN: Say yes, you
want to buy something.
OK.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here is
what I have available.
Premium car.
Trivial drive sample
test, unlimited gas.
test, monthly gold.
Trivial drive sample
test, yearly gold.
Trivial drive sample test.
Which one do you want?
NETO MARIN: You see?
This is listing all of
the SKUs available, right?
So choose one.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Sure.
Let's do the unlimited gas.
NETO MARIN: OK, you
have money, man.
OK.
So now imagine you are saying--
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here's
your order summary.
Your total is--
NETO MARIN: Great.
AUTOMATED VOICE: --$1.99.
NETO MARIN: Oh.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Ready to buy?
NETO MARIN: Yeah, it's good.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Sure.
Yes.
So let's see.
My account is configured.
I have money.
AUTOMATED VOICE: You're all set.
Your receipt is on its way.
Would you like to continue
where you left off?
NETO MARIN: Yes,
let's keep going.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Sure.
NETO MARIN: So it's back
to our action, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: OK, so
this is a cool thing.
Do you realize that we
changed some scopes, right?
Because then we started
the digital goods sample,
and then the
Assistant takes over
to do all of the purchase flow.
And this is important
because then the user
knows who is handling this
purchase is the Google
Assistant.
So as developers,
we don't have access
to your credit card,
nothing like that.
It's very confidential data.
And this is why you
hear these [INAUDIBLE]
sounds to make sure that
you are switching contexts.
And like we said, reading
out these three names
is not a really big
user experience.
So you could use
base cards and you
could use carousel or
something like that.
But yes, I think you
covered the basics, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
Unlimited gas was
consumable, so we
can try to purchase it again
just to show it, if you'd like.
NETO MARIN: Good, good.
Yes.
Try it, please.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: OK.
NETO MARIN: So let's try again.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: So I say yes.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here is what
I have available, premium gar.
NETO MARIN: So
unlimited gas again.
So we are buying a--
AUTOMATED VOICE: Here's
your order summary.
Your total is $1.99.
Ready to buy?
NETO MARIN: Yes.
What's going to happen?
AUTOMATED VOICE: You're all set.
Your receipt is on its way.
NETO MARIN: So
what happened here?
AUTOMATED VOICE: Would you like
to continue where you left off?
NETO MARIN: You
go into their code
and you consume that, and then
will be able to buy again.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Exactly.
NETO MARIN: This is why
we were able to buy again.
Because if you didn't
do the consume before,
like we have now.
[INAUDIBLE] and something
like that, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: Cool, cool.
So I think we covered
at least the basic stuff
on how to do the purchase,
how to build the order,
begin the purchase, handle the
titles in terms of success,
already own it, [INAUDIBLE],,
something like that.
But anything that you would like
to highlight, like a pro tip,
for developers?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
So it's kind of the
combination [INAUDIBLE]
alluded to during
our conversation.
One of them is, always
consume the items
you actually want to consume.
NETO MARIN: Yes.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: And
then the other one,
like you said, about
very long lists of SKUs.
You would want to probably
follow good design
practice and maybe--
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: --shrink
it, or show some rich responses
if you have a screen.
NETO MARIN: Exactly.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah, so--
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
And make it easy for a user to
say the name of the SKU, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Just remember, in
this point of consuming SKUs,
it's very important because
you may want to consume it
as soon as you do
the purchase to avoid
weird flows in your future
part of your application.
So as soon as you receive
that, it's a consumable item.
Consume it.
Of course, if you have a
different logic in your app--
it depends on the user
expanding this thing,
or the credit you can do.
But you always can, for
example, buy this credit--
these coins-- and do your
own inventory control.
And then if you have
cross-platform--
I don't know, other smartphone
platform or something
like that-- you could,
say, use the same credit.
Games are very common
to do this, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Right.
Yeah.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
So OK, and if they
want to see the full--
here you used some
helper methods
to be able to finish
this in 30 minutes.
If they want to
see the full code
and how to do all the retries
and all this kind of flow
to validate all kinds of status
order, where should they go?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: They
should go to our GitHub page
and check out the
digital goods sample.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: This contains
the full code for how to do it.
NETO MARIN: Nice.
And all these directions
on the Read Me
how to get it working
on their account?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Yes.
NETO MARIN: Good, good.
Well, if you have any questions,
if you find any issues
on this sample,
I'm sure Aza would
like to take a look if you
have an issue on GitHub.
But also, you can
find us on Twitter.
So we have our team handle.
That is @ActionsonGoogle.
But if you are building
something cool,
you want to share something with
us, or just give your feedback,
please use the aogdevs
hashtag, and we
will be pleased to answer you.
And also, now we started a
new channel on Reddit, right?
So people can go there
to talk about Assistant,
the actions, some questions.
And if you have more
technical questions,
I think maybe Stack Overflow
is a channel, right?
AZA TULEPBERGENOV:
Maybe a better channel.
NETO MARIN: Yeah.
Our team is working there.
So we are actually answering
when the GDs or other people
don't reply before us, right?
But yes, you can find us there.
And this is very
important to us.
Remember to subscribe
to our channel.
Remember to give your feedback.
What are you thinking
about behind the actions?
What other topics would
you like to see here
in deep dive With our engineers?
OK.
Thanks for watching.
Bye.
AZA TULEPBERGENOV: Thank you.
[STING]